c'est tout ce qui reste d'une école
technique qui abritait des jeunes
recrues de l'armée russe 4 missiles
Ukrainiens de haute précision des aymars
l'ont réduit en poussière quelques
minutes à peine après le Nouvel An ces
images de la milice populaire pro russe
de deniers ont été tournés à main-kifa
une banlieue de nièce le blogueur
militaire russe Ribard
identifie l'école et le régiment
précisant qu'elle abritait 600 soldats
le porte-parole du ministère russe de la
Défense reconnaît la frappe de 4
missiles à ogives hautement explosive
sur ce qu'il qualifie de centre de
déploiement provisoire et par le de 63
militaires tués l'ancien chef
séparatiste prorus Igor strel KOF plus
connu sous le nom de gearkin de plus en
plus critique à l'égard des échecs de
l'armée russe en Ukraine à parler sur
télégram de centaines de morts et de
blessés dans ce seul bombardement au
ministère ukrainien de la défense on
parle de 400 morts et 300 blessés du
fait de la dans l'établissement
la milice prorus de la République de
denies a aussi diffusé des images de
bâtiments endommagés dans la ville en
précisant que l'Ukraine avait mené un
bombardement de masse la veille du
Nouvel An des dommages ont été infligés
à une multitude de bâtiments
résidentiels de magasins de
bibliothèques et deux écoles
qui Ève et d'autres villes du crâne ont
encore été frappés par des missiles
russes mais moins intensément que lors
du Nouvel An l'armée russe affirme que
ces frappes ont visé des fabriques de
drone afin selon elle de déjouer des
attaques terroristes en planification
nouvelles attaques confirmées par le
maire de Kiev vitalicletico qui a passé
la veille du Nouvel An au front à
barkout en 2023 il dit tout ceux qui
sont venus en armes en Ukraine vont la
quitter les pieds devant
défiant lui aussi le président volodymer
Zelenski a parlé dans son message de fin
d'année de plus de 100000 soldats russes
sortent de combat on ne souhaitant
qu'une seule chose aux Ukrainiens la
victoire